let's roll
hello to Crump's to and rook hunter and
memory one in the chat ok let's go here
Knights in the corner tough situation ok
now this is where I really do need to
make sure I devote a lot of attention
yeah what do I do
what a long road ahead these three guys
right here two bishops and this Knight
need to be moved if I want a Castle
kingside
if I want a Castle queenside this rook
needs to be off of that square ok this
seems like a decent start a knight right
here maybe as well what's unprotected
this guy that's the only one so this is
unprotected I don't really see a way to
get at these guys so so quick I like
this is a start followed up with the
night here I'm going to do that the bird
would you call this the bird Birds
opening mmm we're gonna see f4 followed
by Knight f3 where do you think this guy
is gonna go I might actually want to
play him here but then my bishop looks
silly yes the bird is the word as is
being said in the the chat now what
about this bird up here this bishop
ready to come out I'm not worried about
that
let's get my knight here right behind
this pond support points this is a
contributor to the center as well it's
not just I'm not
eenie meenie miney mo 'not right here
alright throwing up a pond here that is
gonna have some central control now
Knight here now
our Bishop here no no no
well I don't know if I want to play here
my bishop looks like a big dummy
although maybe this here night here
Bishop here or something
how about oh wait a second how about
this no no no no no no what's wrong with
this move if I play here then there's a
five and if my pawn moves or captures
there's Bishop check on my king I want
to be very cautious about even moving
this plan so let's not and say we did on
that one night f2 Bishop f2 one of these
two less than four minutes okay
just need to devote some attention still
Bishop F 293 Wow
I just don't know oh man this nights
gonna kill me actually isn't it it's
gonna play here he's gonna hit my bish
up in a couple different ways okay well
I don't know I'm kind of yeah alright
okay what a pain
alright my light-square bishop wants to
play even though this guy looks like a
fool right now mmm
there's a knight gonna play here if it
does I might want to just play here hit
a rock or something and then kick that
night away if Knight g3 I might run home
all run to this first rank on a1 and
then come back out let's see what black
is gonna do
c5 no okay Bishop here no I don't like
like obstructing my center pond so let's
go out here
I'm really looking to Castle kingside
and I'm actually in a spot to do that
next cuz these were the three guys that
I referenced right from the beginning
these are the guys that needed to move
before I could Castle kingside
and there you have it
pesky Knight okay
Bishop g3 and incoming Knight f2 so no I
don't know if that night is gonna be so
much of an inconvenience its trade he
was stupid in the corner anyhow it's
nighttime be alright this night on g6 is
not really a bother
okay now I'm starting to think a bit
better of my position I wonder if I
could run with this v4 idea after I am
Castle I think that starts to be oh well
it starts to be impossible for as long
as this bishops here so that's uh let's
refrain from that refrain a for my queen
would like to play the game one day not
too long from now the Queen wants to
play and she is looking at the a3 square
my pond is also looking at the a5 square
ready to gain some space Queen here
Bishop might come over here let's castle
boom and now Queen a3 and maybe uh well
I don't know about that
let's try this doubled pawns liability
or an asset ah
what's the clock situation it's so far
so good
I really don't want to capture here cuz
I'm just helping that rook out so no
thanks let's go clean
you know you want to play so I'm okay
with this capture cuz I'll have some
play maybe against this pun okay well
getting kicked away a little bit let's
come over here seems like a reliable
square maybe I could uh well I'm gonna
go with the pun maybe I want to come
over like this with my rook some lateral
movement what's this guy gonna do he's a
big dummy right now it's tough to get
this Queen out if the Queen plays here I
have e4 I guess there's a bishop move in
response my bishop looks stupid let's go
rook you weren't doing anything on b1
repositioning I think about that a lot
okay c3 the knight is licking his chops
at this C now that you have the c6
squared
c6 incoming with tempo the knight coming
back I want to get there let's get rid
of the knight you need to go Knight the
pawn hangs what does the pawn move do it
stops Bishop takes Knight what isn't
what does it not do it doesn't it
doesn't have a six protected anymore
okay so now hopefully a mopping up stage
and I think that's TKO I get my pick
bishop or Knight which one would you go
for the night I think is the better one
to go forward with because it's forcing
a queen exchange or you get more
material so this is probably resigned
time unless I get hit with the Comcast
gambit and I was actually
when I was searching for another piece
of the streams to upload to YouTube
today I came across that one that one
where I had just started out this stream
and I was actually saying the only thing
that could maybe I could maybe lose to
here as if there's like the Comcast
gambit and sure enough it happened two
seconds later so I'm dropping this but I
could uh I could care less about that
pani it's open up files it's what you do
about material why not open up the
positions so that the pieces the
material you have have more
possibilities its job the knight is a
beast gluing everything together it's
gonna be something right here pigs
incoming Oh care clean here trouble big
trouble no time left either 15 ticks
one Pig what's better than one pig on
the seventh and you could post that as a
trivia I've been doing a few trivias on
the Facebook page recently what's better
than one Pig on the seventh - two pigs
Oh anything anything anything anything
right here okay time let's go back good
game let's see I don't know if my
initial deployment was good but
hopefully you could follow the reasoning
I go with here I want to make a some
pond move that's going to control one of
these four squares f4 does that the
night jumping right behind it is
reminiscent of birds opening was a
little bit uncomfortable I don't know if
these are not bad ideas by my opponent
now this right here I think I think you
might want to keep it so that maybe
there's like an f6e five move or maybe
like an f6 just to control these squares
I don't know if your Bishop really needs
to be on this diagonal and I don't
really see it as an inconvenience to my
queen okay yes I can't play this b4 move
but I guess I guess alright where's the
one that I kind of thought this right
here maybe I wonder if you should
consider C 5 and then Bishop here just
to have control of this square although
I mean it does we can be 5 but something
tells me maybe get this C pawn involved
before you place your Bishop on the c6
square not so sure about obstructing
this guy that's just a very small
suggestion and maybe you do best to not
take my bishop because this B pond of
mine while though doubled is in your
territory and turned out to being a bit
cramping I mean I mean it allowed for a
great support point as soon as you touch
this B pond
see six is lit up in my mind so that
that's that's a big problem here you
defend it but I'm trying to remove that
and if a knight is allowed to get here
that's gonna spell disaster so I think I
think actually not taking this bishop
just keeping things as is is maybe best
yeah I wonder if actually - it's
something like Bishop back to e8 and
then playing c6 or something even though
your bishop in some sense becomes a
prisoner behind your own pawns here but
I don't know that seemed to turn out to
be a cramping pawn right there on b5
good game though it's easy to easy to
slip up you have the right idea to cover
the important squares but that's just
that's going to be hanging upon isn't it